we are
we are going to be leaving the territory
of uh some of some of you have had high
school chemistry we're going to be
starting to leave that territory
and get into some of the things i talked
about
before that you may have never seen so
for example
um today we'll be talking about
semiconductors
right and what happens when you take all
these atomic orbitals
and you put them into a solid um
and and then by the end of the week
we'll talk about metals
and then next week we're going to talk
about crystals right so that's what's
coming
before we get into uh uh um
semiconductors and and solids
there's one type of bonding we covered
but i didn't put the stats up on the
on the column so i just wanted to kind
of make sure that we
finish that and that was hydrogen
bonding
and there's a little video you know
water
we're not going to go into all the
amazing properties of water but if
you're interested
this is a really cool website that talks
about all the anomalies
of water and and many of water's
properties
are anomalous and much of the reason for
that
is the last type of bonding we talked
about intermolecular bonds we talked
about
last friday which is the hydrogen bond
so remember
our table i just wanted to fill out the
table because i didn't fill out the
table right
that's the type of bond and the model
was some kind of
you know electronegative um
it was some kind of highly
electronegative atom like a
was oxygen or nitrogen or fluorine
so that you drew a lot of charge off of
that hydrogen
and you left it uh with a really strong
delta plus
so that it could then bond to some
other atom it might be the same atom by
the way it was in the cases that we
you know that we talked about i'll just
use the same atom because we used
hf and h2o so then it would be the o or
the f
but it's to a lone pair right on that
atom
that that was the hydrogen bond and the
range
of attraction is in
kilojoules per mole of bonds
is something like let's see 10
to 40. so it's pretty strong you know
compared to some of the weaker things
like london
the hydrogen bond can be pretty strong
and one of these the examples that
is the classic example would be
hydrogen hydrogen
there's the hydrogen bond right there
you see hydrogen bond
between another oxygen with itch
hydrogens
as well now we talked about how water is
so special
because in the case of water not only
do i have exactly two hydrogens in each
molecule that i've
caused this strong delta plus but i've
also got two lone pairs
so the numbers work right in hf that's
also a hydrogen bonded
it can hydrogen bond to itself right but
i've got three lone pairs on each f and
only one hydrogen that i've taken that
charge away from so you still get the
hydrogen bonding but this is the
beautiful balance
oh and there's a video showing water
bonded to each other there it is oh
because there's nothing like just
imagining what a hydrogen bond looks
like
and so of course a hydrogen bond well
okay charges oh it's french pole
right okay oh that's what it looks like
it really if you could get down there it
would be a ray of a laser beam
light it says
hydrogen and that's
and and there it is and this is what's
going on in the liquid right and they're
kind of seeing each other
and they're talking in there but they
feel this strong
strong hydrogen bond okay and that's
happening all over the place and in a
liquid
they are making and breaking all the
time
question
yeah yeah because well it depends right
it depends it's a great question
why do they separate right well they
don't in
ice right so in ice i mean you know they
can
but a nice it's a solid so they're sort
of locked in
right and and so in there you're gonna
have pretty much each water molecule has
four look at this it's you know from
vesper right
four possible four possible bonds you
can make
tetrahedral would sort of but there's
actually lots of ways you can orient
them in a solid so there's many forms of
ice 12
different ways to make a solid of ice
right but but see
here goes in tight
so so here in the liquid at room
temperature
with the laser beams they're coming in
and
and they're bonding but they have enough
energy to break the bond too
so they stick and they unstick because
there's enough thermal energy in the
system
to continuously break them and remake
them that's what that's when it's a
liquid
when is it a liquid versus a gas right
the boiling point remember
that is a proxy we talked about last
friday that is a proxy for
the bonding strength between these
molecules right
if it's a stronger bonding then the
boiling point will be higher and higher
oh water should have boiled at a much
lower temperature
if it didn't have this very special
hydrogen bond which is not
a dipole dipole people try to people try
to write the the physics of the hydrogen
bond as one over r cubed that is not
true
it is not just as simple as it's another
dipole-dipole-type interaction
it's complicated complicated
remember we had covalent bonds were
complicated too
so we're not going to put a simple one
over
r something dependents for the hydrogen
bond
okay good question okay now
uh all right so that's an intermolecular
now we're going to move on to
solids that was our last intermolecular
interaction oh but there's before i do
there's actually
an example question i put there that you
could now answer
which this is actually i just want to
show you the type of okay so we cover
all these intermolecular bonds
here's a question from a quiz last year
lists the intermolecular forces in each
substance
right methane and then you got that
ch3oh right and then you got the ch3cl
right and and so you can do this now
because for methane
all you got is london it's not a polar
molecule all you got is london
there's no hydrogen bonding right
but for ch3oh
do you have hydrogen bonding yeah
you do because if you draw because you
got an h that's had the
the charge taken from it by oxygen a
highly electronegative atom
and then and then you've got lone pairs
on that same oxygen so you can hydrogen
bond
and you've also got london
right now is that it is there anything
else
ch3oh what else is is there any other
type of bond
well the last question you need to ask
is is there a dipole moment
in the molecule because if that molecule
had a permanent dipole
then there's another type of
intermolecular interaction like we
talked about
dipole-dipole so you'd have three right
and for ch3cl well there
you you also you know that for ch3cl
you're going to have a dipole moment
remember we compare dipole moments and
molecules
and if you have a dipole moment in a
molecule then that dipole moment can
talk to another
dipole moment and be interacting with it
so that's a kind of bond
and is that it
london london is always there
it's always there you've also got london
don't forget
right so you'd have dipole dipole plus
london here
right dipole dipole london and hydrogen
just london right so this is what this
is the kind of way i want
and you might be able to think about
well what would a trend like you know
if you think about like okay well if a
molecule just has london
then what does london depend on
right well it depends on the
polarizability
of the charge so that could be something
with acid it depends on the size because
that
tells you how much i say well what about
sih4 compared to ch4
sih which is going to be you know more
strongly bonded
right you can answer that because you
know the only force there is london
and you know for london it's how much
contact area you have is going to be one
of the factors the more contact
the more chances these things can get
close enough and polarized
right and then polarizability would be
the other
good okay all right now we're going on
to solids
now the big picture is
pretty awesome if you look at the big
picture
we have done the electronic structure of
atoms and
molecules right so we've gone through
and we worked our way through the bore
atom the atomic model
quantum numbers aufbau what happens when
you go from one electron to many
and octet stability which is lewis and
vesper
we have also now talked about how
molecules come together in different
ways how the atoms come together in the
molecule
and how the molecules come together in
different ways right dipole dipole
london dispersion hydrogen bonding right
and then there's these forms of
aggregation gas liquid and solid and of
course we're excited about this
so i put my little emoji there
right because that's what we're gonna do
now we're actually gonna
take we talked a little bit about solids
already but now we're to take
the electronic structure that we've
built up
right these orbitals and we're going to
make solids out of them
okay so this is the week where
these are the next two weeks right where
we're going to talk a lot about
solids and this week
this week okay this week
we're going to do the electronic
structure
and next week
we're going to do adams so that's our
plan
right and next week friday we're going
to break a bunch of stuff with parents
so so this week we're going to what do
electrons do in solids
next week how do atoms arrange in solids
and together that gives us so much
understanding
of how chemistry affects properties in
solids
okay so that's the big picture now
here's the thing
why does that matter well because so
many properties can vary by
so much depending on what i just said
how does chemistry affect properties in
solids well
it's it's complicated but look at this
variation
28 orders of magnitude of conductivity
electrical conductivity
28 orders of magnitude that's a lot of
zeros
10 minus these are the electrical
conductivities of different
atoms right different uh
materials and you can see that
it's going to depend on what you have
but it's also going to depend
on so that's the chemistry but it's also
going to depend on the bonding
it's going to depend on how the
electronic structure comes together
and it's going to depend on how the
atoms come together that is what will
explain
28 orders of magnitude that has a lot of
variation
right so we're going to start by
thinking about how electrons
see these solids that's how we're going
to start
now the thing is that these good old
days these good old days
of molecular orbital theory are going to
end
they're gonna have to end today no
they're not ending for like quizzes
and exams don't forget about them but
we gotta move on because this is just
two atoms
two atoms but what happens when we have
like a solid right how many atoms do we
have
we got a lot we got a lot so let's go
i'll go here okay now you know
if you look if you think about that
picture that was our p
i'm going to take 1s orbitals
and let's just think about this for a
second
if you take 1s orbitals and you make and
you have 2 atoms
that come together well they're gonna
you know do just what you see there
where you've got your 1s and your 1s
and i'm even going to fill these up in
the sigma and sigma star
so that would be like two 1s orbitals
that i have either okay so up here i
took
one it was a positive and i subtracted
one
and here i took one and i added one
and remember this gave us this
and this and this gave us the bonding
orbital right
bonding antibonding it all came from
lcao
lcao is a linear combination of atomic
orbitals that's the theory we use to
build up our mo theory
right but now we got to go a lot further
right
so i'm going to because i don't want to
keep adding things
here and here it gets complicated right
i'm trying to find
the the mos for more and more and more
atoms
because i got to put a whole lot into my
solid right
so i'm going to write them on the just
on one side right if i write
the two here like that
and that would be sigma and sigma star
then you know what i'm talking about i'm
taking the two and i'm combining them in
two different ways
but what if i had three well see if i
had
three so i've got three s orbitals now
right so if i've got three s orbitals
then
if you think about it i could also add
them
like that that would be a very nice
bonding orbital right if you add them
you see that they're
they're going to have the same kind of
really nice body but i could also
subtract one in the middle
and if i did that so i had a plus
minus plus there right so those are the
signs right
plus s minus s plus s then
you can see that in between those as i
add these together you have nodes
right so like this is not going to look
very like a very happy bonding situation
i'm going to have something in there
and then something in there that's what
that's going to look like as i bring
them closer and try to add them
i made two nodes here well there's one
other way you could do this and we know
that the number of molecular orbitals
has to equal
the number of atomic orbitals right we
know that so
there's one more that we need because i
started with three s's
and you can kind of see that right you
can see that because if i had
a plus and a plus
if i had done it that way or maybe the
other way right maybe this was
over there but you see i got a i got a
little bonding going on in here between
them and i got an anti-bonding there
it's almost like it kind of cancels out
so you could imagine that that
combination of s orbitals if i add and
subtract them this way it's going to be
somewhere right in the middle
right maybe not so bonding maybe not so
antibody
okay good all right well let's do four
so if i had four if i started with four
this is like four hydrogen atoms let's
say although i'm not filling it yet
but so four 1s orbitals well now
you see i could do this i can add them
all up
and get this super awesome bonding state
well i could also alternate them
so that everything is anti-bonding
look at that right these are going to
cancel as you bring them together
and you're going to get antibonding
antibonding right
but there's also two other options
because in tight
that are in between right here i can add
two and then subtract two and you can
see
these would these are both negative and
as they come together they're going to
overlap constructively so will these but
in the middle here
they're going to be kind of destructive
interference right destructive
and so you're going to have this one
node in between
but in general you can imagine this will
be more bonding
than anti-bonding right so we draw it
down below the middle
whereas up here you could also imagine
something like this
where you start with a plus and you put
two minuses in there
and a plus over there is it just adding
and subtracting it's just i'm taking lco
theory
and moving it to more than two orbitals
okay but that that so now you see that
you can actually understand this from
the number of nodes right
this is like three nodes
this is two two nodes over there
this is one node
and zero nodes this is exactly the
kind of thing we talked about already
but for only two orbitals now we're just
continuing it along
okay you can see why the good old days
are over because
see now we got to jump this up a level
and we got to think how many s orbitals
do i have in a typical piece of matter
how many do you think
take a guess
roughly but take a chunk of
hydrogen this big how many how many how
many atoms do i have
a mole exactly that's why we invented
the mole
so that we could count big numbers by
just saying one
one mole but if i have a mole then i've
got like 10 to the 24th of these
i just went to four i just went to four
right but it just keeps on going so
april does this
so here's like okay one okay
orbital of atom oh i labeled that well
two
bonding antibonding orbitals of
molecules and then you see okay there's
three
there's four five you keep on going
okay they got a little tired and then
they wrote 30
30 30 orbitals
30 is still way way far away see but
if you had 30 s orbitals you might still
be able to kind of see them
see these lines discreetly remember this
is energy space they might actually
remember like these energies are really
important right the lines between the
deltas but if you have a mole
if you have a mole it looks like one
continuous set of lines
these don't really look discrete anymore
right
these don't look discreet and so
if you have a mole of atoms so if you
have a solid
we call that that collection
of orbitals that are all stuck in here
a band we call that a band
okay so if i take now i'm not going to
draw
10 to the 24th 10 to the 24th
s orbitals but pretend
pretend that that's what i have here
then
what happens
what i do is i form a continuum of
states
a continuum of levels for those
electrons and this
they're so packed together we don't even
draw them as lines we can't
right so this is called the 1s
band oh-ho band
it's a band it's a band of states
it's a band of states that's the 1s band
now there's some important rules
that are really just the same but we
follow them here too
and so i want to emphasize them we've
already learned them for
molecules they hold for bands and solids
right so so now for example
let's think about this each of these
orbitals
could occupy how many electrons
two right so i had two electrons
for each s orbital
s orb well you know if you think about
that then
for n atoms for n atoms
and here what did i say 10 to the 24th
because
there's one s orbital that comes from
each atom
so for n atoms then i would have two n
electrons could go
can go can go into
the 1s band right so if i have
oh that makes sense right because i had
two for each orbital and i had that many
so if i know how many atoms i have
right that make up this solid then
that's how many electrons that band can
have in it
all we did is is go from the orbital
atomic orbital picture to the solid to
the mole
right okay why am i saying that well
because
filling filling is
incredibly important and it happens in
the same way just like it was so
important for
molecular orbitals it's also critical
for bands
so filling is like
mo it's just like in mo's start
from
lowest energy lowest energy
then fill up
so you know if you think about this if i
had
now i'm gonna i'm gonna actually say
well okay i made the 1s band
by combining these orbitals now i'm
going to say what a half
which tells me how to fill it now i have
hydrogen
so if this is the 1s band if this is the
1s
band and i have
hydrogen right
so hydrogen has for each hydrogen
i've got one electron but i just said
that in the 1s band for each atom i
could have put 2 electrons so you know
if this is made of hydrogen
that it's half filled which is exactly
what that picture shows
that's the filling you see it's filled
halfway the band is filled halfway
it it's it's like the mo picture
right but it's not because i've made a
continuous band out of it
so instead of putting lines here lines
there and then occupying them with
arrows
i fill them up with 10 to the 24th ish
electrons so we fill bands up like that
and we know that it's half filled
because it's hydrogen
another thing that we know is
that the energy remember this
this is also important right
that that energy
is related to interaction
and overlap this is something we talked
about interaction
and overlap
of the orbitals how how much does that
band
go up and down in energy right and
something we talked about
how much that band goes up and down in
energy is just like in the the
h2 molecule nicely 1s 1s sigma sigma
star
how far apart are sigma star in energy
what depends
on the interaction strength and the
overlap between those orbitals
the same is true in solids right same is
true in solids so how
what is the width of that band
right how spread out over energy is it
okay now so there's some ground rules
now what else can we say okay so there's
the
absolute least bonding state
anti-bonding all the way up there
the most bonding and then you've got
almost infinite number of possibilities
in between
right yeah but the thing is
that filling determines
the properties you you can't just know
the bands or the band structure as it's
called
right but you have to know the filling
and when you have a situation like this
so what let's write this down
when you have partial filling
partially filled
band is a metal
and i will talk about metals on friday
so we will come back to that concept and
the electronic structure of metals
on friday and but today
i want to talk about something else that
happens which is when
you fill not in the middle of a band
not in the middle but maybe all the way
up to the top and there's a gap
that's a different kind of material so
if filling stops somewhere partially in
the band in the middle of a band if
you're filling you're counting
and and you didn't go all the way up
then you have a medal
now but the thing is here we've only
talked about one kind of band
this is the s band what but every single
one of these
i can make i can make band look at this
i can take
a mole of orbitals and make an s
band like that and then oh that was 1s
here's 2s and look at this i can take
the p electrons and make a p band
p 2p band i can do this with every
single 2s
1s right so depending
on a bunch of factors depending on a
bunch of factors
these bands could look different
what does it depend on so this is yeah
so the ba
the way these bands are organized right
we know now that
that these orbitals will come together
like i've drawn there and there
and form bands what is the distance
between these
did they did they overlap maybe
are they very far in energy right these
things depend
on adam
depends on the atom
and the bonding
and the structure
okay
how do those bands look well it depends
and we'll be talking about some examples
but
for now i want to focus on that filling
thing again
on that filling thing what happens
if i you know i just did hi you know if
i fill this 1s
up to halfway it's a metal if i keep
filling keep adding electrons and i fill
this up halfway
it's a metal but if i
stop filling you know if i fill this
and then i fill this and then there's
some
some space in energy and i didn't fill
anymore that's not a metal
that's not a metal so if there's a gap
so there can be gaps between bands
which i just showed you that's between
an s and a p band
right and then the filling determines
the properties and they're so
important right they're so important so
let's talk about that i want to talk
about these
what we're going to do is we're going to
talk about
semiconductors
today and wednesday and medals on friday
okay and we're going to see it through
the vantage point of these electronic
levels
and the next week we'll see it through
the vantage point of atoms
okay so
if you have a gap well you always have
gaps the question again comes to filling
if the filling stops right if the
filling stops
uh let me write i want to define this
very
importantly so if the filling stops
then you have this highest occupied
level so let's suppose i have
filling this is some band
and this is some band and this is
unoccupied
so unoccupied by electrons
this is fully occupied
by electrons now
so what's going to happen well first of
all let's just get some
some terms the last band
that i filled the last band that i
filled is called the valence band
valence band and
we use vb for short and
the first band that i don't fill is
called the conduction band
and as we talk more about these
materials
you will see why they're called that
conduction band
but for now just just trust me in the in
the labeling so
the conduction band and the valence band
depend on the filling
because again it's you know it's where i
filled two now
the top level the very very top level
out of these 10 to the 24th level
that very top one has a special name
it's the vb
maximum that makes sense right it's the
top valence band or the vbn
and the one down here also has a special
name it's the cb
minimum minimum
or cbm
so the valence band maximum and the
conduction minimum are
you know it tells you if you think about
it it tells you
if you subtracted those energies between
those parts of the band
you'd get the distance and energy
between the two bands right
right so the conduction band minimum is
this energy level here
and the valence band maximum energy now
remember valence electro it's called the
valence band it makes sense because
valence electrons
remember are those ones as we talked
about with lewis where
you're you know you've got kind of the
bonding and the action and the chemistry
happening and so this is that top most
state of the topmost valence band
all right this is the valence band
topmost state okay
and there's one more definition we got
to know about this is why we're setting
this
up which is that that energy difference
here oh
that is really important so
the energy of the conduction band
minimum
minus the energy of the valence band
maximum
is equal to something called the band
gap
energy gap it's the band gap
band this is an extremely
important property of materials
the electronic band gap okay
what is the energy difference between
the highest occupied
electrons and the lowest unoccupied
electrons
that's what we're talking about
so if
that filling if that distance okay so
here's
here's an element carbon in the diamond
structure
and just not purple is filled
and not purple is not filled so so you
know that that's the conduction band
right
and that's the valence band and the band
gap which we've just defined here
is the energy difference between those
and for diamond it's really large for
diamond it's really large
so you can see that in fact
the gap is over if we converted this to
electron volts it's more than
is more than five electron volts more
than five electron volts
all right now i mentioned thermal energy
in answer to the question about water
right and room temperature so room
temperature
the energy of room temperature if you
think about temperature as
as an energy of like vibrational motion
right
and you can do that right you use
something called the boltzmann constant
and you can get what the room
temperature energy is and it's something
like 0.025 electron volts
seems pretty small so the point is if
that's the
if that's the energy the thermal energy
i have at room temperature
then if my band gap is so much larger
than that
is so much larger than that it means
those electrons are always going to be
stuck
they're never going to even in some
accident
have enough thermal energy to come up
and be
excited yeah we'll talk about this later
so they're really stuck and and if if an
electron is in the valence band it can't
move very well
it can't move it's kind of stuck in
those bonds
it's kind of stuck in those bonds and so
here if there's electrons all stuck here
and they never have a chance to go up
here
where they can travel freely this is
really going to be an insulator
this is not going to carry electrons
through the material
so that's an insulator when you have a
very large band gap like that
we call that an insulator
okay but see if we compare and this is
interesting you're just going down
in the periodic table if you compare
diamond to silicon
to germanium right well see
what happens is the band gap gets
smaller i'm still
filling them all the way up to the top
of a band
so i'm not a metal if i'm a metal
it's because my filling stops somewhere
in the middle of a band
so i'm not a metal i'm a semiconductor
and not an insulator and the reason i'm
a semiconductor
is that my band gap is kind of small
enough so that
electrons can kind of jump from here up
to there
sometimes sometimes
that's why it's called a semiconductor
there they kind of conduct electrons
right so the electron
can get up to the conduction band in a
semiconductor
more easily than an insulator and that's
why it can conduct
electricity much better than an
insulator many many many orders of
magnitude
but the way that we have talked about
getting electrons
excited getting electrons excited is
with light
and we can do that for solids too we can
do the same thing for solids
right and so if i if i plot
the absorption if i take a solid
and i shine light on it there's
something called the absorption
coefficient
the absorption coefficient which is
really just
a measure of how you know
how far down into the solid did that
light have to go
before some electron got excited by it
how well does it well okay different
solids can absorb
electrons differently but the main point
is if i plot that versus energy
you know for something like silicon
the band gap of silicon is 1.1 ev
so that's what it would look like for
silicon because you know
this should be wavelength
wavelength because you know
because as you get to lower so you know
that above
it's exactly like for atoms if i shine
light like remember the bohr model if i
shine light
on an atom that has enough energy to
promote it up
then it can go right but the difference
here
is that for silicon
see for silicon that's right there for
silicon there's this big empty space
with no bands
it's just like the atom when there's no
states
i cannot have an electron there
i'm stuck so the electron can be here or
it can be here
and so the light the energy of the light
has to be at least the band gap
to get it up at least the band gap to
get it up
right so what that means is that if i
had
so why does this go to zero with with
increasing wavelength what it means is
that if my
valence band looks like this and my
conduction band looks like this
yeah and now my light is coming and i
want to take an electron and promote it
up
well it cannot be the electron
cannot be cannot exist
in side the band gap
there's no states there it's just like
we talked about with atoms
but now we've got almost infinite states
here no states there
and then again we start with infinite
places where it can be
right what that means is that if i shine
light on it the only way silicon
the only way it can absorb this light is
if the light has
energy greater than the band gap
or wavelength less than the band gap
that's why
i drew it that way right so it goes to
zero so it's going to absorb in
wavelength up to a certain point
and then if i go higher in wavelength
those are energies that are too small
it's going to like try to absorb here
but there's nowhere to absorb to
so it can't right but if it has enough
energy oh look at this
this is also different i could absorb
here
or here or here i can take all those
higher energies and absorb
light kind of continuously
unlike in the atom where it could only
be the level to hop you from n
equals two to n equals four right but
here i have
an almost continuous set of states
except in the band gap where i have no
states
so that's what the absorption would look
like for silicon
and if you look at the band gap this
very very important quantity
there's carbon there's diamond there's
silicon
there's germanium right and you can see
that as you go
to heavier and heavier elements
you change the gap
you can understand this from what you
know about the electron levels in atoms
because in an atom
right in an atom remember as a
you know if i get heavier and heavier
those electrons
all the way on the outer uh you know the
outer edges of the atom they're more
weakly
bonded to the atom right they're weaker
and weaker and weaker
right so the energy is higher and higher
remember it like so it's like instead of
being these deeper energy levels that
have more body
more energy in them lower in energy
they're less and less energy
right well so you can you can imagine
now
that those are what you're starting with
those are what you're starting with
these right these are the atom levels
that you're starting with so if you're
going to make your atom
have electrons that are more weakly
bound
with energies that are higher that
aren't as deep and don't have as much
distance between them
right in the energy landscape then the
gaps will get smaller
now that is a very simple picture
a very simple picture of why the gaps
get smaller it happens to work for this
column
right so you know if you look at this
and some people would even call this an
um a metal because that's such a small
gap but i like to call it a
semiconductor
right but if your gap is zero if your
band gap is zero
it means there's no gap so
by definition you're in the middle of a
band
you're somewhere in the middle of a band
and if you're in the middle of a band
you're a medal you didn't fill that band
all the way up right
but if you filled it up and then there's
a little gap between you and the next
level
then you're a semiconductor or if it's
much greater
like greater than three electron volts
three and a half electron volts
then you're an insulator okay
now so you can imagine now why right so
as the as the interactions get stronger
you can imagine those distances can get
larger
and so you could have larger and larger
gaps which can explain this trend
but as i said before where did i put it
it depends
not just on the atom and the original
energy levels but on how those bond
together and we'll talk about that on
wednesday
and it also depends on the structure
which we'll talk about next week
so it's not just as simple as that but
you can understand
you know basic trends this way for some
of the columns
okay now um okay we'll get to that on on
friday um now the goody bag gives you a
way
to probe this so what's in the goodie
bag the goodie bag has
a way of measuring conductivity now i
just told you that you cannot get
connectivity unless you have electrons
that are able to make this jump
to make this jump they've got to be able
to go up
from the valence band to the conduction
band if they don't
do that they're not free they're stuck
in these bonds
right you got to get them free so they
can roam around
and not be stuck in this bond or that
bond right
this measures that this measures that
right this measures whether electrons
are in the conduction band
you've also got some leds and some leds
and this is the critical piece here why
do you have
two kinds of leds because on the one
hand
what you're doing i'm giving you a way
to excite
electrons so i'm giving you a way
to actually promote electrons so you've
got 10 to the 24th electrons in this
valence band
this would be the vb and this would be
the cb
and what you're doing is you're shining
light
right with different frequencies which
means different energies
okay that's what the right hand side
gives you it gives you
different energies of the photons so you
have a way now
of shining energy on a semiconductor and
that's the second piece
the semiconductor is what an led is
it's a semiconductor if leds were
insulators they wouldn't work and if
they're metals they wouldn't work
because the way an led works is actually
just the opposite
here i'm shining light so that an
electron gets promoted and i can measure
that
with my my voltmeter but i could also
put electrons in with a current that
gets them up here
and then they drop down and emit a
photon that's what an led is
right that's what an led is it's just
the reverse and so what i've given you
on the left
are different semiconductors
because you see just just like a
different you know
if i'm running current through like i am
on the right you see those are different
colors
that means that i must have different
gaps
you know that you know that already from
the work we did with bohr
and the color or frequency of light that
you could get out of different
transitions
but it's the same here did an electron
you know did i put an electron up here
and then it fell down and gave off some
lambda
right that lambda has to equal the
difference between
the i mean it just equals the band gap
right it equals the band gap
because the electron was put up to here
in the cbm and then it drops down to the
vbm and it emits a photon that's what's
happening on the right-hand side but see
you've also got on the left-hand side
you've got sensors
because it's just leds on the left see
but if i hook those
up if i hook those up to
uh the voltmeter well i'm hooking up a
semiconductor to a voltmeter
so i'm hooking this up and i'm reading
is there any current
yeah and the answer in a dark room is no
unless you make it really really hot
don't
because you have to go to very high
temperature but what if i shine light on
this now
well if i shine light that has the right
energy
to put electrons up in the in the cbm
from the vbm then i'll read something on
the voltmeter
so by giving you different leds on the
left
i'm giving you different band gaps you
have in your hands
different semiconductor band gaps and by
reading whether
there are electrons in here or not you
can tell what
frequency of light i shined on them so
they're both
emitters of photons and detectors of
photons
and it all comes together because you
have a semiconductor
which happened because you took 10 to
the 24 states
you put them together you had gaps
between them and you filled all the way
up
to one of those gaps and that gap was
around one
or two electron volts we will pick this
up
on friday and go further i mean on
wednesday on wednesday
you